Well, aloha!
I was born and raised in Hawaii.
Very excited to be here, you know, at TEDx Tokyo.
You know, I met Patrick over at TED a few months ago and...
...he's just an amazing individual and he's been a huge inspiration for me.
So truly, it's an honor to be here.
And just gonna tell you a little bit about myself before I start playing.
This is my ukulele.
And I've been playing since I was four years old.
My mom, you know, she played and she taught me how to play.
And I've been passionate about this instrument ever since.
Well, here's an idea for you.
I truly believe that the ukulele is the instrument of peace.
You know, it's the instrument of peace...
...because I truly believe that if everyone played the ukulele,...
...this world would be a better place.
So, I'm gonna try to prove that to you in a bit.
But I started out playing a lot of Hawaiian music, you know, things like this.
And then over the years, you know, as I got older...
...I started listening to different styles of music.
And then, those three chords became things like,...
...you know, I start really rockin' out on this thing.
So, I'm gonna play a little tune for you.
This is a piece that was inspired by one of my favorite flamenco guitar players,...
...the great Carlos Montoya.
This is a piece entitled "Let's Dance".
And here's what something I call flamenco ukulele.